okay here we go time travel test number
one
Scott fire up the uh
the van thing
Breakers are set emergency generators
are on standby good because if we blow
the grid I don't want to lose a tiny
here in the 1950s excuse me he's kidding
I can't say things just just it was a
bad joke
you were kidding right I have no idea
what we're talking about time travel
here either it's all a joke or none of
it is we're good
get your helmet on
Scott I'm going to send you back a week
let you walk around for an hour then
bring you back in 10 seconds
make sense
perfectly not confusing good luck Scott
you got this
you're right I do Captain America
Anaconda three three
two one
what this this doesn't feel right
yes it's Scott
[Music]
what is this can I get a little space
yeah yeah bring it back I'm working on
it
it's baby
as a baby he'll grow bring Scott back
when I say kill the power kill the power
oh my God
somebody peed my pants
oh thank God but I don't know if it was
baby me or old me
or do just me me
I travel
what
I I see this is an absolute win